holy crap that's the coolest thing ever
yes we're just three episodes away from
the season finale of American Gods and
I'm here to help break down the episode
and point out some of the cool things
you may have missed along the way so put
on your Ted Nugent bandana because here
we go the episode begins backstage at
what appears to be some sort of
vaudeville show these types of shows
featured a variety of entertainers like
mimes
and they were popular from about the
1890s to 1930s and we get our first
American Gods musical number
[Music]
check out the background of the set
which is a rendition of the Great Hall
in Valhalla
mr. Wednesday even announces that the
name of the hall therein is the Regis
which is derived from an Icelandic codex
which holds many old norse poems it's a
fitting name since this theaters in the
business of song and dance and of course
we have Wednesday's Ravens mutant and
Hugin watching over we then get our
first glance of doner the great who will
later find out is actually Thor he
carries Thor's hammer Mjolnir we also
get a glimpse of Miss Colombia decked
out in her American flag costume
Colombia deriving from Christopher
Columbus who discovered America although
was actually the Vikings hundreds of
years before him after the show ends
Wednesday is congratulated by the crowd
but the most interesting thing is this
mysterious man who will later find out
his technical boy we then have a few
Nazis arrive and yes Nazis were more
public in America before World War two
so it isn't out of the realm of
possibility but it was all a memory
inside Wednesday's head while he dreams
they're outside Gamora a mall built over
the Dwarven center of power last episode
mentioned Sodom and it's interesting
that they now bring up Gomorrah since
both were cities mentioned in the book
of Genesis renowned for their sin and
vice they're here to see Valen who they
need to reforge the runes on Odin's
spear gun near fun fact I used to live
near this actual mall and it even has a
little theme park inside it too the
closing of the mall is also a metaphor
for the old gods slowly dying away they
haven't even gotten rid of the banner
that says the future is 1989 but the
most important part of this scene is
when Wednesday tells shadow he reminds
him of his son donar the Great and we'll
get into that in a bit back at
blackbriar mr. world has a cool little
diagram depicting quote small attacks
that may light the spark he's likely
referring to events that will sway more
people to his side he then has a chat
with new media telling her a cryptic
message that victory requires a power of
breadth and scope she says she'll up her
game and turns into a cat emoji this
character back at the Regis mr. Nancy
works backstage telling Columbia she's
got to go on he also has some deal with
her that he gets 20% of her worshippers
but Columbia is busily oiling up donar
who says that he can't run a
way with her to California because
Wednesday needs him but Columbia says
Wednesday is just using him and she
alludes to her being the Wild West and
manifest destiny manifest destiny being
the idea that the United States was
destined by God to expand across the
continent no wonder she wants to go west
to California in the main theater
Wednesday tries to make nice with
technical boy by giving him his best
showgirls a Samba and goof unis I
couldn't find any details on a Samba but
goo foon was the ancient Norse goddess
of agriculture and fertility technical
boy isn't enjoying the hospitality and
shows tremendous hubris in the face of
Wednesday who remarks that he may be
gaining followers now but what happens
when his technology becomes obsolete
foreshadowing his eventual demise when
new media and mr. G take over this scene
also sets up what could be technical boy
joining the side of the old gods stone
are shows off his strength again with
more illusions that he's Thor with the
girls unable to lift his sacred hammer
hammer vogner's ride of the Valkyries
plays in the background while Wednesday
keeps tabs on tech boy a man named
manfred inquires about donar but
Wednesday wants to know why he wears the
angle cross of Phil fought on his arm
band the angle cross of Phil fought was
used centuries before the Nazi version
of the swastika adorning sword hilts and
funerary urns largely a religious symbol
Manfred says he's with the Friends of
new Germany which was an actual
organization in the United States in the
1930s which sought to bolster support
abroad for the Nazi Party back at the
dead Maul century says that de Valen
isn't capable of forging the runes the
strength to etch such runes of war would
require great power which only the
leather jacket worn by Lou Reed can
provide at the Regis Manfred wants to
sponsor donar for the world
weightlifting competition which
Wednesday thinks is a great idea
donar will be elevated to his former
glory which in turn will elevate the
entire pantheon of old gods we also see
how much sway Odin has in his son's
decision while Colombia isn't too
pleased
Nazis frighten her it's also interesting
here to note how they're setting up
donor as a sympathetic character who
dreams of running off with Colombia
telling her that once he wins they can
move to California and do whatever they
want of course this does not have a
happy ending we then
get another musical number as Colombia
sings about not being fenced in a
metaphor for the expansion of America
through the Wild West but it begs the
question what happens to Colombia when
there's no more places to conquer no
more lands to explore Bishop Hammersmith
over here buys Lou Reed's jacket for
$7,500 but it's all a ruse shadow barges
in posing as Secret Service taking in
Wednesday for using fake bills and of
course the jacket is now evidence so
they walk away scot-free in a backroom
filled with creepy mannequins shadow and
tear gates Wednesday about his son we
learned that he was indeed Thor but he
went by his given name donar a
particular interest is how Wednesday
says shadow reminds him of donar that
they share similar characteristics but
the death of donar is too painful for
Wednesday to bring up my guess is that
this all links to why Wednesday hasn't
revealed himself to be shadows father he
could have distanced himself from him in
order to avoid being hurt the way he was
when he lost donor but at the same time
as i theorize Daffy you episodes ago he
could also not be revealing it in order
to protect shadow we then get a flurry
of newspaper and radio ads depicting
donor strength and eventual rise to fame
it confirms that this is 1934 and that
he seems to be quote harnessing the
power of the gods I also like how the
articles themselves are written in Latin
Manfred talks to donar about a proposal
which donar isn't too pleased about man
Fred wants donar to purposely loses
matchup with the German competitor
mister Nancy appears and let me first
say that I am loving Orlando Jones he's
just killing it this season
he tells donar the story of a young boy
born to a world where men could not rule
so this boy traveled through time to
find a world where men could he made a
deal with man exchanging fire from the
gods for the ability to rule which the
men then used to find his homeland and
destroy it his own lust for power
destroyed the very thing he loved and
that's what Nancy is getting at donar
made a deal with the Germans and is now
paying the price for it just like Nancy
did who was the boy in that story do
Valen has given the sacred power of Lou
Reed and now given the strength is able
to reforge the runes claiming that it's
now ready to be healed as soon as this
happens the alarms that blackbriar go
off alerting mr. world that the runes
have been
he says that things are going ahead of
schedule but that his friends in the
valley will be ready he's referring to
Silicon Valley and whatever scheme he
has cooked up with mr. G back in the
1930s donor decides that after his last
show he's gonna move with Columbia to
California he says he's going up pledge
himself to her and I think that distinct
use of the word pledge here evokes the
Pledge of Allegiance he's pledging
himself to America
of course muna and Hugin are watching
Wednesday introduces Columbia to
technical boy who has a proposition to
reform Columbia into Our Lady of the war
effort
ever since Lady Liberty came into the
picture Columbia has slowly been losing
followers shield need this if she's
going to survive and Our Lady of the war
effort would be a perfect fit for Miss
manifest destiny over here because
believing God has chosen America to win
the war would be a huge advantage now I
also think it's interesting that
Libertas the Roman god of freedom is
brought up again here a huge emphasis
was placed on it in Episode two and I
had the crazy theory that shadows mother
could potentially be Libertas herself
check out my episode 2 video if you want
to know a little bit more about that
Columbia needs more time to think about
it since she just decided that night
she's going out west with donar but
Wednesday tells her that he left with
the Germans without her which of course
is alive he tells her it's time to
manifest her own destiny a cheeky nod to
her being the encapsulation of manifest
destiny and in the background you can
faintly hear America the Beautiful
playing in the alleyway of the Regis
Wednesday confronts donor who has
decided not to do the championship
instead running off with Columbia but
Wednesday tells him she won't be coming
and they get in one of the coolest
scenes of the series young year and
Mjolnir Duke it out with mule near so
powerful it shatters Wednesday spear in
half seriously this is the kind of stuff
I've been wanting to see in this series
since season 1 God's battling it out
using their weapons and powers Wednesday
is so shocked at how powerful donar is
stating that it's only a fraction of
what's to come he tells them that power
like this you cannot walk away from but
that's exactly what he does and in 1942
donar commits suicide the only death
gods can't come back from
notice this somewhere in America painted
in blood and they we can do it rosie the
riveter Poe
Derr which has been superimposed with
the face of Colombia suggesting that
Columbia took technical boys offer and
donar lost the love of his life
hence ending his own shadow asif dona
rode with the Valkyries to the afterlife
and Wednesday isn't sure but judging by
his face it isn't likely then the
episode ends with Wednesday singing one
of the best-known American songs of the
Great Depression brother can you spare a
dime in what seems like his now rundown
theater with donar gone he has lost his
show and must move on to something new
so where does that leave us with only
two more episodes left in the season at
the time of writing this the promo for
episode 7 hasn't yet been released but
it feels like we're getting closer to
our big season climax with Goong you're
almost ready and mr. worlds plans
underway I'm predicting some future God
deaths the reappearance of technical boy
and shadows true heritage to be revealed
we also still have Laura's resurrection
and her attempt to find this special
blood infused with love I'm really
enjoying all the New Gods for being
introduced to and excited to see where
this season takes us that's it for this
episode guys
I hope you enjoyed it be sure to give it
a like and subscribe and stay tuned
because I'll be coming out with a game
of Thrones breakdown sometime tomorrow
and come check me out on Twitter at
think story whitey until next time
remember daddy loves you very much